this supplement comes with a positive
affirmation what did you say
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we are back with another
harper's bizarre
celebrity what i in a day review so
this is an oldie in fact i think it's
one of the og food diaries videos
on their site but it was heavily
requested by a lot of you in my dms
so today we are going to be reviewing
victoria's secret angel
miranda kerr now before we get into it
let me tell you a little bit about my
sponsor squarespace
which i know you've heard me talk about
a lot before because
i'm just such a big fan of how easy they
make this entrepreneur life
so in addition to everything that i do
here on youtube i also coach a lot of
dietitians who want to learn how to blog
and make videos and social media posts
and so many of them struggle with the
whole
website thing i get it honestly it can
feel
like a huge beast if you're not very
tech savvy
and i'm not but squarespace is a super
intuitive
all-in-one platform that makes it so
easy for anyone to set up a website blog
or online store
regardless of your niche one of the
features that i really like
is their donation feature so you can
encourage people to support a cause of
your choice
on your site by easily gathering
payments online
you can also set up members only content
and can easily communicate to your
members
through their email list programs
honestly it is so nice when the
technology just kind of works
because i feel like i otherwise struggle
with this way too
much so if you're interested in getting
started you can check out
squarespace.com for a free trial
and then when you're ready to launch go
to squarespace.com
slash abby sharp to save 10 off of your
first purchase of a website or domain
and super quick before we dive in here
you can pause the screen
or look at the description below to
check out the disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current
or previous experiences with disordered
eating and eating disorders
i will be evaluating meals really just
based on their nutritional merit
alone which says very little about their
overall value
now while the new food diaries format
follows more of a description of what
the celebrity eats
these old days give me a little bit more
of an accurate look
at the specific recipes that the
influencer is using
so i will have a better opportunity to
actually break this one down
in a little bit more detail for you now
if that is not supporting
your food journey by all means sit this
one out
and of course don't forget subscribe to
this channel and ring that little bell
so that you never miss
out on a video alright folks let's do
this
so one of my favorite things to have
first thing in the morning is
hot water with lemons it's a really
great way to kind of
kick start your digestion is full of
vitamin c
cheers oh my god this video is
ancient in youtube years this is legit
three years
old and here we are it's 2021 it's
supposed to be a brave new world out
here
and we still haven't shaken the damn
lemon water fad wow
and that's what i call high quality a
tool quick fact check folks because
i'm not gonna go over the evidence or
lack thereof
again lemon water full of vitamin c
truth lemon water is delicious truth
lemon water is a good way to get in more
water truth
lemon water will help kick start your
digestion
fake news let's move on
i'll then make a smoothie and these are
some of my favorite ingredients to
include
almond milk fresh papaya spinach
blueberries and raspberries almond
butter
a great source of protein and then last
but not least
i add my little cora organic skin food
supplement so
this contains noni contains acai
blueberry matcha green tea i used to
drink it as a liquid it's
so much easier okay so this looks like a
pretty great nutrient-dense smoothie
also love how she served it in a
little coffee cup but we got great
amounts of antioxidants and fiber in the
veggies and fruit
plus some healthy fats with the almond
butter i do think that there is more
room for a little bit more protein
i mean i know that she did mention that
almond butter is a great source of
protein
but in the serving that she served
herself it's like
only three and a half grams so not a
whole lot
but of course depending on what else was
for breakfast
or meals the rest of the day that really
may not be a big deal at
all but we do have research to support
the benefits of having a protein-rich
breakfast
for things like supporting weight
management satiety hormone regulation
and reducing nighttime snacking and
overeating
so my little quick tip here would be to
just bulk this meal up a little bit
maybe by adding a higher protein milk
like soy or pea protein
adding in some greek yogurt or silken
tofu or of course you can just add a
scoop of the protein powder of your
choice
as for the cora organic skin food
supplement
i first just need to point out that
along with all of its health benefits
that they list on the website
they also list a positive affirmation
yeah i'm not sure what a positive
affirmation has to do with a supplement
powder
but um i guess it does make it sound a
lot more
zen um yeah
also disclaimer probably would be nice
because this is actually miranda's own
brand
but anyways this element contains a
variety of potent antioxidant rich
ingredients
like noni acai berry blueberry and
matcha green tea
plus some prebiotics i actually bet it
tastes
pretty good so that may be a great
reason enough to add it to a drink
and there's no denying that all of those
ingredients
are nutritious and good for your health
but for your skin specifically
that's kind of up for debate so first of
all if you haven't heard of
noni it's a south east asian fruit that
is rich in vitamin c
e beta carotene and polyphenols like
irritoids
now while there has been some research
on the use of noni juice for things like
arthritis
immune health heart health and exercise
endurance
i wasn't able to find anything specific
for
skin i do assume however that the
connection is through the role of these
antioxidants
in protecting against oxidative damage
in the skin
now matcha acai berries and blueberries
on the other hand
do have some research to support its use
for skin health
now the unique antioxidant in matcha
egcg
has been shown to help reduce dna damage
from uv rays
as have the antioxidant category
anthocyanins
found in blue or purple containing fruit
like blueberries for example or acai
however most of this research has been
done either in
mice in test tubes or through topical
administration
like in a face cream so it is hard to
know
how much of these kinds of ingredients
you would have to eat
to see a measurable difference in your
skin
we also don't even know how much of
these superfood ingredients
are in a packet of this powder since
the only micronutrient on the nutrition
label online
is vitamin c and since she's already
packed that smoothie she had with
vitamin c in real whole foods
she's just going to be peeing out any
excess
bottom line i believe that all of the
ingredients in the supplement are super
nutritious
and some may have unique antioxidant
properties
to help support healthy skin but do we
have reason to believe that adding this
one thing to your day will make any
measurable difference in the look
and feel of your skin probably not
but again if this adds a flavor to your
smoothie or your water that you really
enjoy
great chuck it in and if you're having a
hard time getting in antioxidants
in your day fine this cannot hurt
but for miranda specifically a woman who
must have like two fridges just for her
greens
i'm not sure it's really going to do
much
the woman most likely just has been
blessed with naturally
beautiful skin all right let's see what
else is next
it's one of flynn's favorite things to
have for breakfast i like it because
they're healthy for him and he likes it
because they're really yummy
contains free range egg oatmeal and
a little banana put them all in the
blender
now just turn this on add a little
coconut oil
make little little mini pancakes
you're gonna just let the dog out for a
second whoo let the dogs out
got out sometimes i use two of these to
just kind of get underneath there
as you can see super quick and easy to
make
and i'll add a couple of little
raspberries a little coconut nectar
okay so this is a classic baby led
weaning pancake recipe that is really
great for kids
and adults alike regardless of age
but miranda says that she makes these
pancakes for her son flynn
and she likes them because they're
really healthy
and he likes them because they're really
tasty i actually make pancakes kind of
like this as well except
i usually up the protein or the healthy
fats in them with some greek yogurt or
pureed cause cheese in there
uh things like ground flax or hemp parts
or i add in some spinach or other
vegetable for some color and extra iron
so i'm to leave a link to some of my
recipes below in case
you're looking for some more inspiration
now miranda doesn't say for sure that
she eats these as well but
i'm going to go and work with the
assumption that like most of us busy
moms
she's eating the same meals as her child
and that's actually what i
always recommend we don't need to make
kid food and adult food children will
actually
learn to eat and enjoy family foods that
your family is eating with them
if they have you as a model to show them
how
so i say eat with your kids and eat
foods that you want them to eat
so if you want to learn more about my
family feeding philosophy you can check
out my video on the division
responsibility
right here as for the coconut nectar i
think that these alternative
natural sweeteners always come off
sounding like a way healthier than
regular sugar
but the fact of the matter is that while
some like maple syrup or honey
may contain greater amounts of certain
micronutrients and antioxidants
they're still largely recognized in the
body
as sugar having said that coconut sugar
or nectar
does have a slightly lower glycemic
index due to the inulin fiber in the
coconut-based sugar
however the difference is pretty
negligible for the amount of sugar that
women hopefully be consuming so
we're talking about between 60 for table
sugar
versus 54 for coconut sugar
so i say choose coconut sugar if you
really like the flavor
which i personally really do but not so
much because
it's so much healthier than white sugar
as i said in my video on sweeteners
whatever you decide to use to sweeten
your drinks or your food
just choose something that you actually
enjoy and try to use
modest amounts of it it's important to
do exercise that you really enjoy
for me i really enjoy yoga just doing a
few
stretches and yoga poses
really helps me feel energized and
grounded and ready for my day
so i love this and i'm totally aligned
with this philosophy now if you watch my
video on
joyful movement in my intuitive eating
series you may remember me saying
how important it is to find an exercise
routine
that you can actually stick with and
that starts with finding something that
you actually like
all movement is good movement so don't
think that you need to be doing a 60
minute crossfit session
for it to count so
for lunch i'm gonna have salmon with a
little crushed garlic
turmeric and fresh lemon with a side
salad of
sprouts and arugula cucumber purple
cauliflower
and avocado and then i make a simple
salad dressing with olive oil lemon a
little apple cider vinegar and little
sea salt
this looks really delicious and there's
definitely
no shortage of nutrient-dense foods
going on here so
we've got those healthy omega-3 fats in
the salmon
plus you've got healthy fats in the
avocado and olive oil
we've got loads of fiber-rich veggies in
the salad
i mean i would say that we could
definitely add a carb here especially if
that breakfast was just a smoothie and
she didn't have the pancakes that her
son had
i don't really know so if that was the
case my tip would be to add in some
cooked quinoa
or rice or sweet potato to the salad or
to stuff
everything into a pita for a nice little
handheld
lunch but in general i appreciate that
this girl
doesn't fear fat and this looks really
super delicious no matter how busy i am
i really try to take a moment
and just really be present with 18 and
really enjoy my food
love this philosophy um i think that
this is just
such valuable advice given how hectic
i'm sure her schedule can be as a
working mom
and entrepreneur but research has linked
mindfulness eating strategies to
reducing the risk of metabolic syndrome
inflammation and mood disorders and of
course also
in improvements in diet quality and
self-confidence
so it is definitely worth trying to make
eating
an experience that you actually want to
cherish
so good and tasty let's take a look at
dinner
so one of my favorite meals to cook is
my slow roast chicken
add onion garlic fresh lemon turmeric
rosemary put it in the oven cooks for
seven hours
and then i have that with sweet potato
mash i just leave the skin on
and then you pop them into steam so this
is one of my favorite salads it's super
simple
we have cabbage here with baby spinach
parsley
a little cilantro finely chopped
cucumber
olives halloumi cheese sunflower seeds
pine nuts and celery okay so another
very beautiful meal and this one gets
top marks for balance
satiety and satisfaction in my books
so we've got lots of quality protein in
the chicken
we've got those slow digesting high
fiber carbs in the sweet potato mash
and we've got a salad with lots of
antioxidant rich veggies
plus some healthy fats in the seeds and
nuts
and i am low-key obsessed with halloumi
cheese and i don't think i've ever seen
a youtuber cook with it so brownie
points
to miranda for throwing that into the
mix but seriously this meal is
inherently
obviously very healthy and if we look at
the
different components you're really
talking about some of the most
nutrient-rich ingredients that money can
buy but when put together
it like looks and feels very much like a
chef worthy meal something that you
could easily get at like a really fancy
trendy restaurant
in la this is comfort food
without the side of diet culture and i
think that comfort food as a term
has often been co-opted by diet culture
to mean
bad foods but to me it can easily be
nutritious foods that just feel cozy and
comforting to the
soul that's what this meal feels like to
me
and as a result i think it's likely just
as emotionally satisfying
as it probably is physically satiating
all right so let's talk about miranda's
day starting with the stats
and a quick trigger warning here that i
am about to talk numbers
so if that's something that you want to
skip ahead for you do you
so according to my super crude
calculations we're looking at around
1800 calories
assuming she did have some of those
pancakes and she's getting around 27
of her calories from protein 30 from
carbs
and 43 from fat so this is by no means a
keto diet but it is still pretty low on
the carbs and high on the fat
she's also hitting pretty much all of
her micronutrients though she's
a little bit low on iron zinc and is at
the lower
range of healthy for fiber at 27 grams
now as for her antioxidants i actually
didn't even include the skin supplement
in my analysis since the website doesn't
even list anything
other than vitamin c but without it she
was coming in at over
300 of her vitamin c needs uh 1500 of
her vitamin a needs
and 200 of her vitamin e so
i think she's probably good on that
front
now while overdosing on vitamins isn't
usually a huge concern when it comes to
food
depending on what her supplements offer
in terms of vitamin a
and e she could be at risk of vitamin
toxicity so that is definitely something
to watch
we can get too much of a good thing
now there's obviously a lot to like here
as miranda's diet is
clearly nutrient dense and her meals
look
delicious colorful and fresh her intake
while possibly a little bit lower than
what i would have predicted for her
isn't the extreme deficits that we often
see here on
my channel and she doesn't seem to be
demonizing any particular foods
or food groups here so we got pancakes
you got cheese you got oil you know all
commonly shunned ingredients here in the
youtube wellness space so
i definitely appreciate that so i think
that all i would suggest
is to maybe just mix in a few more whole
grains so that's rich in iron
so she could switch up her smoothie and
do
some oatmeal sometimes maybe add quinoa
to a lunch salad
swap out the chicken sometimes for a
plant-based protein like soybeans or
lentils
also tahini tahini is a really great
source of iron so
she could easily add that you know a
little bit into her dressing or
put a spoonful into her smoothie as for
her relationship with food
um ultimately this one video doesn't
give me nearly enough information to
comment on the adequacy
of miranda's overall diet nor does it
really tell me a whole lot about her
food philosophy
or her relationship with food but i will
say that i appreciate
that i didn't hear a ton of explicit
diet culture language
or demonizing any particular foods or
food groups
the worst that we heard was a little bit
of misinformation about lemon water
but let's be real it wouldn't be a
victoria's secret what i in a day
without
some claim about drinking lemon water in
the morning
so i guess in the grand scheme of all of
these videos i've reviewed
that seems pretty benign so in
conclusion
a quick reminder to please be kind in
the comments
and that this video was in no way a
criticism of miranda herself
or really even her diet i'm hoping to
now use these videos as kind of
teachable moments to teach
gentle nutrition so hopefully you were
able to
take some of these useful tips and ideas
away on how to optimize your meals and
snacks
and on that note that is all from me
today thank you again to squarespace for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you